on voit un effet se conforter un profil
de criminels qui passent à l'acte
en réalité sous l'effet de deux
effecteur d'abord une manipulation qui
passe souvent par les associations qui a
le même se camouflent sous un objet
sportive sous un objet éducatif parfois
sous un objet cultuel et qui sont en
réalité des instruments de l'islam
politique
et puis deuxième source de manipulation
vous l'avez dit les réseaux sociaux
globalement entendu il faut donc
impérativement je vous rejoins tout à
fait nous attaquer plus fortement encore
à ceux qui manipulent et à ceux qui
transmettent line
nous allons donc nous allons donc dans
le cadre actuel déjà renforcé le conseil
des ministres l'a fait aujourd'hui les
10 heures les dissolutions
d'associations ou de groupements de fait
est proposée à la représentation
nationale d'élargir les cas légaux ou
c'est disposent ces dissolutions
pourront intervenir mais vous l'avez dit
ya aussi toute la question de la haine
en ligne du recours aux réseaux sociaux
vous avez emprunté à monsieur le
président du sénat une appréciation dans
laquelle je me retrouve volontiers sur
ses réseaux et surtout sur le recours
que certains enfants
vous savez que nous avons en réalité
deux sujets sept heures non seulement
effectivement une jurisprudence du
conseil constitutionnel que vous avez
rappelé que je crois l'ensemble de la
haute assemblée connaît nous avons aussi
des sujets de directive communautaire à
faire évoluer pour mieux responsabiliser
les hébergeurs je serai sachez le
dès vendredi à bruxelles pour rencontrer
plus
leurs commissaires et la président de la
commission européenne
et c'est l'un des premiers sujets que je
vais aborder avec elle nous avons déjà
pris avant même les terribles faits dont
nous parlons cet après-midi des
initiatives sur le champ communautaire
ça sera une de nos premières priorités
et puis effectivement dans le texte dont
je parlais tout à l'heure et vous avez
bien voulu faire référence à mon
intervention hier devant l'assemblée
nationale
il nous faut et je suis sûr que le sénat
y concourt à trouver une voie juridique
tenant compte de la jurisprudence du
conseil constitutionnel
il n'appartient pas au premier ministre
de commenter les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel mais rendant beaucoup
plus effectif vous avez raison
notre action déterminée contre la haine
sur les réseaux sociaux je vous remercie